[Music]
and my bad bro news
my bad submitted by we did
it we did we did
it what is it that they did india's
richest
man who put his brother out of business
is now bailing him out
what he put his own he put his brother
out of business and then he bailed him
out
damn that's a lot of money to prove a
point dick energy
that is yeah to teach him a lesson
that's a big
indian dick energy it's like punching
your brother in the face and then
helping him up
yep so this story is about mukesh
ambani cash what a dope name that is a
dope name
and his brother anil and mukesh for me
anil is the one that lost it because she
ain't got nails he lost about a nil
you gotta know no uh yeah so
he's estimated mukesh is estimated to be
worth about
or more than 50 billion
um 50 billion is he single
that's like up there yeah like
top 10 up there
like one percent up there yeah and his
brother
i think is worth about maybe something
300 million
oh he's poor bro
how is the money different that's
billion that's like mufasa and scar
so what happened here was their dad
that's mufasa and a cat
the run of the litter like a mufasa and
a mouse yeah
uh i watched that movie mufasa and a
mouse
because mufasa is friendly so their
father
died back in 2002 and so
his dad built like a whole bunch of
businesses
and just like a whole business empire
and
i covered industry like like energy
retail and financial services and so
these brothers yeah these brothers ended
up dividing all these businesses amongst
each other and obviously one was way
more successful than the other which one
mukesh just kind of just chose the right
ones maybe
yeah maybe i'm uh very racist because i
think
when i think india i think farms indian
restaurants
telemarketing what do you mean by indian
restaurants you mean just restaurants
restaurants serving indian food and
local food and uh
telemarketing outsourcing centers and
bollywood film making people i picture
like aladdin marketplaces
that's not india though but but it's
yeah like an outdoor bazaar
outdoor like snake charmers and stuff
and then three guys on one motorcycle
like lots of rugs going up and down yeah
how do you tell
someone they're scary in a non-racist
way
gary remember we're at banu the indian
restaurant
there's an indian restaurant that we
like going to like in temple city
rosemary or whatever it's delicious
you talk about the one that's the
supermarket right yeah that place is the
best it's bomb
and then the owner of it he looks like a
bollywood villain
you guys see him yeah you mean the old
man yeah he has that head wrap he has a
head wrap he looks so nice eyes are
[ __ ]
got dark circles and he got that curly
indian mustache that comes he's like
jafar
he's been putting wax in all the time no
no he's he's painting him that way but
he looks very sweet no but i thought
you're talking about the ball fat guy
oh you know he always has the the head
wrap thing so he goes he sees taika and
he thinks he's cute so he's like making
faces at him
but taika keeps like like kind of scared
and i don't think that he knows how
scary he does not look to a kid
but i also don't know how to tell him
like yo your indian ass face looks
[ __ ] scared
not like that oh my god i mean all his
workers are also indian
okay but they all just look just look
very kind they don't look that
stereotypical
bollywood and you don't have to do it
with the indian part then
you're a scary face a bollywood villain
yes so when you come out to my kid and
you're like
like maybe you should not do that
because you're trying to offer them can
you really want to get on taika's good
size offering candy sweet
very sweet very sweet i love this man
but i didn't know how to
break it so i'm like yo maybe if you
trim the mustache
or like i don't think it's your place
yeah i don't think it's your place to
break anything to him because i don't
think he's worried about that i don't
think he's well kept wondering why
he was wondering yeah he was he was like
he's like how come this kid don't like
me no that's your own
i wish this kid would like you know he
seems like he comes from a very big
family or like very family oriented uh
space yeah
he like knew like okay he's just afraid
of me okay i'm gonna go over here like
he didn't care
oh excuse me jafar can you go over there
please
i should tell him he looks scary oh i'm
gonna tell him how do i tell him but i
don't want to look racist but his
scariest
indian faces like super scary
oh [ __ ] that's so funny let me say bart
and go back to this story
if you guys don't believe me test me
bring your baby there see if they cry
i don't have one he's probably just
crying because he's a stranger
all up in his face he didn't cry at the
other waiters didn't cry at any
before or after he blew [ __ ] a smoke
pipe in his face
all right back to the store oh yeah what
happened so these siblings have
had this like they've just always been
against each other because they're like
i wanted the coal mine
no you got the coal mine that's why
you're rich something like that they
just call it like just this crazy
sibling
rivalry saga and
back in 2016 mukesh
he nearly put out a nail out of business
or like a year later after that because
in 2016 damaged his own dad's companies
well because he ended up doing this like
price war type of thing
where he was offering something like his
company was offering something that the
rest of the telecommunications
industry couldn't really offer so then
it was putting out a lot of businesses
telecommunications you were right
out of business and uh so
it ended up coming to the point where
anil
was in debt to the swedish mobile firm
and he owed about 80 million dollars
well that is nothing to a 500
billionaire or a 50 billionaire person
the other phone has 3 million
300. oh okay i thought i said three
million out there and that's his net
worth too we don't know how much cash he
has
yeah you could pay 80 million there
that's his net worth net worth he
we don't know what his cash is we might
have 10 million i see
yeah so then it was either pay it by
this date
or face three months in jail and so it's
what jail
i don't know swiss jail i don't know
yeah but like we're gonna come over to
india and extradite your ass
i don't know damn so the brother ended
up
coming in right before that deadline and
paying off his brother's debt
and so it's been like this very like so
a lot of people are like oh look they
reconciled that's so nice and then
the mukesh's company ended up spiking
ten percent
after that after him oh my god all the
moves like a pr move
it seems like it wait but how did he put
the it said that the brother put him
his business out of business because of
the price tactics
that he was doing with his own company
no yeah so here are the brothers by the
way simpler than that
it's even more simple than that what it
is is like
if i do this he's gonna owe me forever
and i could bring that up every [ __ ]
time yep
is the billionaire the one with more
hair yep
i knew it of course cash in the nil you
got those chickens for [ __ ] teeth too
[Laughter]
that's him reminding him remember how i
bailed you out
remember i know it's kind of weird that
i'm helping you even though i took you
out but would you take it
so now dale is just like oh you know
like we're just so
thankful for my brother keeping family
alive and strong
whatever he was not that was part of the
deal
maybe yeah did he have to say that
publicly yeah yeah yeah he's like
staying true to our strong family values
thank you so much brother for helping me
that's probably how he said it
i am yes i'm very indebted to you
forever whatever
yeah so now that's just making headlines
all over the place piss me the [ __ ]
off what what would you my brother being
a piece of [ __ ] like you be petty and be
like [ __ ] it i'm going to jail
oh yeah really yeah and then i'm in
there i'm like [ __ ] man i [ __ ] up
yeah i'm so stupid in jail either too so
he probably know what it's like
rich people go to the same jail maybe in
india who knows who knows
who no it was like a swiss jail because
you owe the swiss government i was
confused about that i wish you could
just file bankruptcy like every other
company
no maybe that doesn't work in india
maybe not
but they don't have what chapter seven
chapter eleven whatever
if you don't pay your debt you're going
to die 7 11 you know what i don't get is
like
if you want them to pay pay their debt
why would you put them in jail
yeah because they're not going to want
your money yeah if you want them to pay
their debt let them
find a way to pay it off yeah atlanta
do they not
then you would be mandated to just pay
out of your assets
i don't know can you imagine being a
billionaire though
like the level from a millionaire to a
billionaire because i could kind of
imagine like a low-level millionaire or
upper class
but then that's like a king
yeah because he'd need more than three
times his net worth to even make it to a
mil
to 1 billion
you [ __ ] up on the billion i didn't
[ __ ] up i did not [ __ ] up
but i just want to give you some more
info saying that nail's net worth
actually dramatically decreased like
crazy
to 300 million so they're saying that it
was about
at least 31 billion also he was a
billionaire too
yeah he used to be in the billionaires
club now oh [ __ ] how do you lose all his
money
um so they're saying that gambling
hookers you probably just made some
really poor investments wasn't the smart
that's a huge
drop that's huge i know you bought too
many jet planes what happened
there you didn't buy hair that's for
sure this was in 2008 too so that's when
like everything
went to [ __ ] around the world gonna
start buying things online
he was like that's true what if he
bought a lot of stocks
interweb whatever
that's almost like someone going to the
poor house
for someone that's a billionaire from 30
billion to 300 million
can you imagine even thinking that that
you lost something
when you add 300 million and you're
depressed because you
because you went from billions to
millions it's all like comparative
yeah to the because i bet you he was sad
he went down two zeros i mean i can't
even imagine
being sad because i only have 300
million
i'm not going to sympathize with you can
you imagine taking away two zeros though
so even if you had a hundred grand in
your bank account now it's
ten thousand wow ow no no no you have
one thousand
one thousand that's crazy taking away
two
zeros 30 billion to 300 million that's a
good way to paint
that's [ __ ] crazy from 100 000 to
1000. yeah
a hundred thousand to a thousand
thousand dollar left what the hell you
gonna do dance what
that's all i understand ten thousand to
one dollar yeah he gets to be
and you're gonna go to jail yeah and you
gotta be your brother's [ __ ] yeah
well you only got three hundred million
i wanna know how how do you mismanage
money that bad
i wouldn't even care if i mismanaged my
that bad it's like okay
you wouldn't care not if i went from a
bill 31 billion
but then you're also assuming that he
worked for it his
his dad built all that [ __ ] right that's
what i'm saying he probably doesn't give
a [ __ ] he's like
management of money that absolutely
because it's like he got
given to you and then you're like yeah
just i mean that doesn't mean he knows
[ __ ] about business from a poor person's
perspective too so it's like
500 million 10 million one million no
that's not one
what if your lifestyle standards is a
billionaire because you grew up in that
world
and then now you have to be with one of
those guys you're not a king anymore
how does that feel like we're used to it
we've been 10 000 to what are we saying
i can't relate because whether you have
50 million or a billion it's all the
same to me
yeah but for us it's almost like going
from
this point to the poor house right
oh mukesh is older by three years oh
not even by a lot but it's like if this
blessing
was all given to you and then you went
to the poor house
so you didn't have to work for it like
how do you mismanage money that bad
but you went there's middle-class people
that get
things passed down to them and then they
mismanage it and then they lose it that
could be a failed industry too
because i don't i don't think it's
probably spending habits it's probably
like whatever business investments he
had
and it could just be an entire industry
that just failed and he had all his
money in that industry
anil i told you get out of pagers i told
you i know he goes but all my doctor
friends have one
yeah i know this article that i'm
reading off of it
it says 300 million but then when i
google his name on
wikipedia it says 2 billion is his net
worth maybe he went up
yeah maybe it went up because that's
2008 maybe his brother threw some
billions at him yeah cheer up
[ __ ] boom
[Music]